the creators of safe moon have been
indicted one of them has been arrested
and it's a lot worse than we thought now
I have the indictment right here in
front of me and let me say I have chills
looking at this we've been calling out
safe moood for over 2 years this is my
eighth video on them so I can't express
how vindicating it is to see this and
before we go further I just have to
thank you guys without your support
helping shine a light on this I truly
don't think this would have happened and
I think I would have been sued into
Oblivion by now so thank you I I don't
want to get too sappy here let's just
jump into this indictment our top
suspects on the page United States of
America against Braden John Corone Kyle
naggie Thomas Smith you guys know those
are our top three suspects as well we
have over two hours of video dedicated
to them and now they're going down now
also attached to the court docket is a
notice of Thomas Smith's arrest already
but we also have an announcement that
John Corone has also been arrested in
Utah while Kyle naggie is still on the
run but I'm sure he'll be found
eventually but let's see the charges it
looks like they conspiracy to commit
Securities fraud nice conspiracy to
commit wire fraud very good and
conspiracy to commit money laundering
very spicy so these are not huge
surprises from us uh you know as I
reflect on this though I I remember that
they actually sent me something
threatening me they sent me this cease
and desist they were going to sue me
they were going to they told me I was
going to go to jail uh that violation of
the statute of causing them emotional
distress is punishable by up to 5 years
in prison I still have that set aside
probably I'm going to frame it but I'm
just struck by the irony that now um it
looks like they're the ones who are
going to go to jail now I'm going to try
to keep this from being too much of a of
a Victory lap here we're going to talk
about the main meet of this indictment
um so obviously a lot of this won't be a
huge surprise you know obviously safe
Moon advertised itself as a safe
investment vehicle because of their
liquidity pool which was supposed to be
locked forever um it wasn't as we've
covered in detail it was used as a piggy
bank by Kyle naggie Thomas Smith and
John Corone for whatever they wanted
according to this they talked about
buying luxury Vehicles you know
obviously they did some of that but this
indictment also shows the conspiracy
side of things goes further than we knew
back in March 16th 2021 naggie asked
John Corone quote should we be honest
with the team about pulling out of the
liquidity pool for the project now now
Corone responds to this let's draft up a
statement Thomas you and I need to talk
about how to message that properly so
they're saying right there we haven't
been honest maybe we should be honest we
got to talk about how to break it to
people that we can dip our hands in the
cookie jar here but instead of actually
telling people this coron then said they
should quote update the safe Moon white
paper and call it a day in other words
just silently update it which they did
and then the next day coroni messaged
Thomas Smith make sure you specify we
won't touch the liquidity pool which of
course as we know it was a lie now
despite internally saying they should be
honest they weren't instead they tried
to slowly change their wording so that
no one would notice what they were doing
which is robbing everyone um now we
documented these slowly changing public
statements a year ago but without all
the backend
Communications now that we have that it
looks a lot more Sinister here's that
clip the money's locked up it's right
there in the read me it's automatically
locked up or wait was it autol loocking
cuz I kind of read that too well that's
probably the same thing unless it wasn't
locked at all uh-oh this is confusing
safe moon appears to be contradicting
itself maybe we should go to the CEO of
safe safe Moon so he can explain it once
and for all so the lp lock is automated
not automatic automated and automatic
are not the same thing hm that didn't
help well maybe maybe we go to the
source code that they copied from B
token and figure out what's really going
on here surely B token wasn't a rug pool
so we have this B token code and B was
kind of a smaller rug pole oh well
that's that's even worse how are we
getting out of this one fellas our big
difference you're going to find that
we're never going to rug okay so now the
picture is complete we knew that they
were lying to customers and privately
changing you know the messaging but now
knowing they conspired to do it to hide
it from the public I think that's what's
so interesting there hence the
conspiracy charges because they talked
about it privately and organize this
whole thing now I actually have some
other news for you guys the FBI aren't
the only people going after them today
we also have the SEC drafting a
complaint today against you guessed it
uh safe Moon us LLC Kyle naggie Braden
John Corone and Thomas Smith so they're
also going after them for fraud you
guessed it so there's a lot here in this
one as well a lot of interesting tidbits
we have John Corone engaging in
227,000 wash trades apparently which is
where you buy and sell something at the
same time for the same price basically
it's like creating false volume on a
token um and making it seem like it's
more popular than it is in addition to
that they also broke down how much money
was stolen by our three alleged
criminals so according to this table
coron stole $54 million from their
locked liquidity pool in B&B Thomas
Smith took 77 million they took even
more in the form of safe Moon tokens so
for that and millions of other reasons
our boys here I'm happy to finally say
after 2 years are joining the Wall of
Shame where our criminals go when
they've been finally indicted ladies and
gentlemen Thomas Smith Kyle naggie John
Corone we got him